[Music]
it was the world's largest freestanding
cylindrical aquarium
1500 tropical fish living out their
lives in the foyer of a Berlin luxury
hotel but early on Friday morning that
Marine dream Came Crashing Down the 25
meter tall cylindrical tank burst
sending one million liters of water
rushing through the hotel lobby
there are shirts everywhere the
furniture everything has been flooded
with water and of course I think
destroyed by this huge pressure so it
looks a bit like a war zone no it's a
huge aquarium just yesterday we watch it
and we were so amazed from its beauty
beautiness and suddenly it's all gone
everything's a mess totally mess
two people were injured as a tsunami of
broken glass debris and fish washed
through the building and out onto the
streets of Central Berlin the hotels
restaurants and shops were also heavily
damaged
it sounded almost like a firework but
the hotel actually shook inside
uh I I could describe it as a
and I jolted out of bed and turned
around and
I didn't see any movement so I didn't
know what the heck was going on it's
still unclear what caused the tank to
burst hundreds of people had been
staying at the hotel and have now been
forced to leave the building but what
about the fish we've not yet been able
to walk the first floor completely which
is probably where these fish will be but
the thing is that the water is
completely leaked out and about 1400 of
these fish that were in this aquarium
could not be saved either
hundreds of smaller fish had been housed
in aquariums under the hotel's Lobby
without electricity for their tanks its
feared many may have suffocated and if
any fish are found alive a number of
organizations including the Berlin Zoo
have offered to take them in
Alex beard Al Jazeera